one of our paraffinic Samanta of our
philodendron from a film character
asuras yes I will forward to you during
the last three years we have been
supporting our home authorities in order
to dismantle an organized criminal
network who have been laundering the
profits of prostitution and trafficking
young woman though today is a very
important we are the main target is
traveling from Spain yeah please do so
yeah the main suspect is a Finnish
national living in Marbella in Spain and
he managed these websites advertising
sexual services by women both in Sweden
and in Finland you have music on your
daughter the company will give us all
the information voluntarily so there's
no need for our search okay give us the
main suspect has been arrested in
Finland and they have also found some
carrots and other evidence to help
dismantle this organization we follow
the money
the Spanish judge issued freezing orders
that was sent through your just to six
national prosecutors this way we managed
to fish shares in companies owned by the
criminals bank accounts and to seize
over 500,000 euros in cash
[Music]
to achieve this we had five coordination
meetings here at the auditors and the
national authorities agreed on where to
prosecute the suspects by working
together we ensure that arrests searches
and seizures could take place in
different countries at the same time
without ureas this outcome wouldn't have
been possible organized crime and
tourism don't know any borders therefore
yo just brings together prosecutors from
all EU member states and beyond in order
to make Europe safe
[Music]